تقول شركتا الأدوية Moderna وPfizer أن
لقاحات فيروس كورونا المحدثة
أظهرت استجابة قوية ضد
أحدث نسخة فرعية من فيروس كورونا. إن
السلالة المعروفة باسم ba 2.86
متحورة للغاية ووفقًا لمراكز السيطرة على الأمراض والوقاية منها يمكن أن
يكون لديها معدل إصابة أعلى بين
أولئك الذين  لقد تم تطعيمهم أو
أصيبوا بالفيروس في وقت سابق، وقد تم
اكتشاف المتغير الفرعي في
الولايات المتحدة وبريطانيا ودول أخرى
أيضًا، وهذا وفقًا
لما
يدعي صانعو الأدوية على حد سواء أن هناك زيادة في
استجابة الأجسام المضادة ضد الفيروس، وكل منهما
في مراحل مختلفة من الموافقة  ولكن من
المتوقع أن تكون متاحة في
الأشهر المقبلة ربما في وقت أقرب على الرغم من
انتهاء إعلان الطوارئ، لذلك على الرغم من أن
فيروس كورونا لا يزال يمثل
تهديدًا عالميًا، إلا
أننا ما زلنا نرى اتجاهات مقلقة لـ
covid-19 قبل موسم الشتاء في نصف
الكرة الشمالي
تتزايد حالات القبول في بعض أنحاء الشرق
الأوسط وآسيا في
أوروبا
وتتزايد حالات العلاج في المستشفيات في
عدة مناطق
ورامون أستاذة علم الأوبئة
في
كلية فيلدنج للصحة العامة بجامعة كاليفورنيا وهي معنا
هذه الساعة من لوس أنجلوس
مرحبًا بكم مرة أخرى، لقد مر وقت طويل،
شكرًا لاستضافتي، لقد مر وقت طويل،
نعم، وهذا أمر جيد أعتقد في
بعض النواحي
أن رئيس منظمة الصحة العالمية
تحدث عنه أه، أنت تعرف
العدد المتزايد
للعدوى السرية على مستوى العالم وكان لديه هذا
القلق بشأن البيانات الحالية هنا،
فالبيانات محدودة
فقط في 43 دولة،
أقل من ربع الدول الأعضاء التي
تبلغ عن ذلك لمن تقدم 20 دولة فقط
معلومات عن حالات العلاج في المستشفيات،
لذا على المستوى الدولي هناك نقص في
الاختبارات أه مثل البيانات التي يتم جمعها
وهنا في  تظهر أحدث أرقام مراكز السيطرة على الأمراض والوقاية منها في الولايات المتحدة أن
أكثر من
17000 شخص تم إدخالهم إلى المستشفى
الأسبوع الماضي، أي ما يقرب من 16 بالمائة أه
في أسبوع ولكن هل هناك
مشكلة مماثلة هنا مع احتمال عدم
الإبلاغ في الولايات المتحدة
خاصة بعد التصريح بـ
انتهى جمع بيانات الصحة العامة في شهر
مايو. لدينا الكثير من المشكلات عندما يتعلق الأمر
ببيانات البيانات لأنه ليس لدينا نفس النوع
من التقارير الصارمة التي كانت لدينا في
ذروة الوباء ولكن أيضًا معظم
الناس إذا كانوا  يتم إجراء الاختبار
في المنزل، وبالتالي فإن أولئك الذين
أبلغوا عن أن هذه النتائج لا يتم
تسجيلها في أي مكان، لذلك ليس لدينا حقًا
أي فكرة عن الأعداد الحقيقية
للحالات ولكن ما نعرفه هو أننا
رأينا ارتفاعًا طفيفًا في بيانات مياه الصرف الصحي.  لقد
رأينا حالات دخول المستشفيات بدأت في الارتفاع،
لذا فهذه مؤشرات
واضحة جدًا، فنحن نشهد الكثير من انتشار فيروس كورونا
بين السكان، ومهما كان ما
نراه من حيث
عدد الحالات
المسجلة، يمكننا أن نفترض ذلك  هناك
الكثير هناك